we did the the trivia question in the
last segment i kind of threw that on it
really wasn't fair you know what i i'm
in a good enough mood today to admit
that that was an unfair trivia question
and i'm giving you the first pick
wow what a nice guy you are i can't even
believe i can't believe that okay i'll
take it then
i'll take it um but this is easy i mean
i i think you would take this same one
with the first pick
taking the kansas city chiefs yeah sorry
when you talk about mahomes tyree kill
and travis kelsey let's go with those
top three right i was wondering who the
third one was going to be but it makes
sense kelsey makes the most sense i
gotta go with kelsey there yeah i mean
sammy watkins dangerous certainly we
know that uh but not in the lineup
enough kelsey
certainly one of the top two or three
tight ends in football tyree kill
certainly one of the top two or three
wide receivers in football mahomes
without a doubt the best player the best
quarterback in football so bam i think
that was an easy one it's very nice to
you mike you know you're really get
you're getting soft in your old age 55
years old from one day you give me the
first pick of the draft wow i'm
impressed
one day close to 56 baby all right uh
what what when i turn 56 assuming the
show's still on the air will you get me
for my 56th birthday assigned lawrence
taylor jersey will you commit to that
now
i you know what i'll commit to that it
won't be a lot of pressure on me i'm
just going to have to drive my dad crazy
hey big films
hey big bill did you call lt but we'll
try to get that done i would like that
i'm actually looking forward to turning
56 now that's good next year won't be as
bad as i thought it was going to be all
right
i could go a lot of different directions
here and i i it's a sliding scale right
um
here's why i'm doing it yes i am i'm
going to go
seattle seahawks
i'm going to go
russell wilson
chris carson
dk metcalf
right one of the top three quarterbacks
in the game chris carson a vastly
underrated running back and dk metcalf
showed us enough last year that he
should have been drafted at the bottom
of round two
the best rookie receiver of all of them
in 2019 now his teammate from
mississippi aj brown was no slouch but
dk metcalf was great the arrow was
pointing up for that trio and you know
people keep looking for reasons to write
off the seahawks keep looking for
reasons to write them off they're going
to keep winning games and keep making to
the playoffs and keeping in the
conversation for potentially advancing
to a super bowl
yeah i mean that's crazy as long as
number three's there you know with pete
carroll leading the charge and john
schneider building a roster like you
know people are crazy to count the
seattle seahawks there's a culture there
that just sorry that ain't going away
and hey it's a great pick by you i had
them written down as well you know it's
not one that's going to like you know be
a household triplet name quite yet but
it's one that's coming up and i think
it's gonna be on the you know a
household uh uh you know
basis there but wilson awesome metcalf i
think is a rising star like you said and
chris carson does anybody run harder in
football than chris carson i mean you
couldn't pay me enough money to get in
front of him and tackle him i know that
all right uh hard for me not to go with
like
the place
where
at least when i was younger the original
triplets originated and i'm going back
to the big d going back to dallas
because yeah you got dak prescott you
got amari cooper
you got zeke elliot i don't care who you
are i have a hard time thinking that no
matter who you are and if you're
following football all three of those
guys are top ten at their position in
the sport at the very least i think you
could say that the very least they might
be higher in some people's type of
rankings but uh prescott franchise
quarterback zeke even though i was
underwhelmed with the way he was last
year you know he's still a really damn
good running back physical you know they
ride him they try to the style of their
their team is built on you know a lot of
ways his ability to run the football and
then amari cooper
you know
explosive awesome rat runner we showed
him on a weekly basis you know breaking
people's ankles last year so that would
be my second pick
yeah and i wonder how long it's going to
be dak zeke amari
before it becomes dak zeke cd lamb
yeah right right or does it become dak
cd lamb and amari
and zeke is the one that gets left out
you know that i that that crossed my
mind too when i was thinking about this
draft
all right i you know
i i got a couple of creative ideas for
maybe later oh oh i'm doing this one i
i'll tell you later the one i was gonna
do
uh if if we really want a compelling
trio of offensive weapons
how have we overlooked so far
kyler murray
kenyon drake and deandre hopkins hiding
in plain sight i just took your next
pick right out of here right right off
of your pen with your little notebook
there kyler murray kenyon drake deandre
hopkins chris
yeah that i was hoping i thought about
taking them last round because yeah
that's that's exactly right i mean
that's that's a special three
especially within that offense kenyan
drake really fits it kyler murray is
special we're both expecting super
stardom and come on hopkins you know it
might be the best receiver in football
so good one by you there i didn't think
you would do that damn it you really
messed up my draft plans here
man do i want to go with potential here
or more of a proven commodity i think i
you know i'm going to go down to new
orleans i i think it's disrespectful for
me not to pick these three you know
there's a few teams here that are in
this running but brees kamara
and michael thomas again i i just think
that's a group that's battle tested
awesome at their craft you know
understand what they have to do on a
plate of play-by-play game-by-game basis
kamara out of the backfield as a runner
or passer is amazing drew brees come on
we know as a legend and then michael
thomas is just an absolute machine of
toughness and everything like that and
hey these three guys are the reason that
they've been in the conversation with
the best team in the nfc for the last
three or four years so uh that's pretty
hard one uh not for for me not to pick
right there
uh how how dare you omit taysom hill
from that conversation he could have
been i know the replacement quarterback
or running back not at receiver though
he's not close to michael thomas yet but
but hey by next year by next year it
very well could be hill camara and
thomas
i it could be and you know which is
crazy is some of these teams that have
triplets really have quadruplets as you
start to go through it and then you
start to go well no wonder they're good
on offense it's more than three guys you
got to worry about it's four or five and
yeah taysom hills certainly came into uh
my thoughts and listen jared cook the
way he can play tight end too i mean
there's certainly some weapons down
there to be wary of in new orleans
all right i i'm gonna go defense on you
i'm i've i've saved it
don't go defense i was just saying let's
do a defensive draft tomorrow but okay
fine okay well we can do that i i i okay
we'll do that that's fine then we don't
have to spend all day thinking of a
draft now i got to find the one that i
was going to do how about this how about
this and this leads into a tiny little
bit of news todd gurley has passed his
physical with the atlanta falcons
finally how about matt ryan todd gurley
and julio jones if todd really fights
anything like what he was a couple of
years ago at falcon's offense you know
with with the buccaneers and the saints
getting all the buzz in the nfc south
let's not sleep on the falcons if todd
gurley can play like he did he's going
to have a chip on his shoulder he's
going to have a red-hot poker uh where
red-hot pokers don't go and he's going
to be ready to prove the rams wrong and
anyone else who's doubted him whatever's
going on in that knee he's gonna find a
way to fight through it so he's passed
his physical let's make him the uh the
uh the coroner's not cornerstone but one
of the three great falcons players
potentially on offense yeah well first
off i think your point about like them
being kind of one of those you know sl
you know sleeper teams i'm with you
you're right first off it's a big year
for them we know that it's going to be a
little bit of desperation from the
coaching staff and the organization that
way you know it might be changes made if
there isn't some you know
a playoff caliber team in atlanta but
matt ryan is certainly awesome julio
awesome and i'm with you todd gurley you
know we disrespect him a little because
we're so spoiled by huge plays and
offensive explosion last year but still
a good year it just wasn't a great year
and i think this year he's going to come
back with a vengeance for sure
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports